here's Stephen Colbert with his little
dance number because I guess legally if
you're sold out and I mean sold out
s-o-l-d unless also
s-o-u-l-e-d if you're sold out uh late
night television host you have to dance
and sing about vaccines and debase
yourself in front of the American public
[Music]
let's see
look at those clapping feels
what is going on and this is comedy this
is comedy and you know we all know damn
well that if Donald Trump had been
president still at that point when that
originally aired and he was pushing for
the vaccines at that point that they
would have all been against the vaccines
right so and now it's like well where
are your dance numbers Jimmy Fallon and
Stephen Colbert where are your dance
numbers about all of the vaccine
injuries the people that are having
heart problems the young men that are
dying in very very bizarre rates we'll
get to that in just a moment nothing
about that because you guys always give
the machine what it wants and what the
machine wants is people to be afraid
they're losing control of the narrative
and that's why they're becoming more
hysterical at the exact same time that
really is it because people aren't
watching that stuff they're watching
shows like this people or were just
outside maybe taking walks breathing
fresh air but mainstream culture
and mainstream entertainment they are
collapsing by the minute and the people
who just feed the machine they're
becoming less useful to the machine it's
what I was always saying about Brian
stelter remember Brian stelter he was
always saying the exact thing that the
machine wanted Donald Trump said very
fine people on both sides Russia
collusion Brett Kavanaugh is a serial
rapist he was always giving it what it
wants and then at some point the machine
says well we don't need you anymore
you're just useless and that's why he
doesn't have a subscription thing or his
own show anymore you got a gig at
Harvard but that's just the machine
protecting their own nobody actually
cared about Brian stelter but he was
part of the machine so people talked
about him it's the same thing sort of in
in the way I'm framing this around
Fallon and Colbert but these people who
give the machine what they want it
cannot end well for them and that's what
I was trying to discuss with Bill Maher
a couple months ago you may remember
this but isn't that crazy that you're
right that all the all the comics that
were supposed to put everybody to bed or
whatever it is they all went bananas
left I mean but these guys are terrible
like Kimmel to me is just [ __ ] you
may be friends with him I know a lot of
people
yeah like he's Colbert
yeah like those guys to me they're just
the worst sort of partisan nonsense you
want everybody but the good part of that
is we don't hide it like he doesn't like
me and I don't like him and we don't
deny it and we don't like it no but he's
nothing yeah he's nothing he's very
successful no no but he's just giving
the machine what it wants all the time
you giving you for my differences with
you I totally respect you as well said
yeah giving the machine What It Wants I
wish I had thought of that phraseology
that's exactly right
foreign
[Music]